he is a power broker a king maker
len mcclaskey helped ed miliband become
labour leader
and jeremy corbyn hold on to the job but
after 10 years running unite the union
his power seems to be waning his chosen
candidate rebecca long bailey
failed in her bid to lead labour
mccluskey himself is due to stand down
in the next 12 months
and now he faces accusations of cronyism
over the union's development of a new
hotel
conference center and union base in
birmingham
and its construction contract awarded to
a company owned
by a friend the now almost completed
building may be in birmingham
but the foundations of this story are on
merseyside
len mccluskey was born here he worked on
the docks and joined the union
but it's also where he made links that
would last a lifetime
the man on the left is paul flanagan he
runs liverpool-based building company
flanagans mccluskey described the firm
as a working class family who've made
good
and never forgotten their roots
flanagans was given the big contract
to build the hotel overseeing health and
safety on the project
a different company owned by david
anderson
the son of former liverpool mayor joe
anderson
all three men have been arrested on
suspicion of bribery as part of a
corruption investigation
not linked to unite they all deny
wrongdoing and have been released under
investigation
there is no suggestion of any criminal
wrongdoing in the union's dealings with
either company
but there are now growing calls within
labour for an investigation into unite
the obvious answer to a lack of
transparency is to have an independent
inquiry and i think that's absolutely
the right
thing to do i think that's what the
members would expect i feel
angry i feel this is an outrageous abuse
of positions
to use members hard earned subs
to fund a project that's gone
catastrophically wrong and there's been
no apologies
the development was originally supposed
to cost around seven million pounds
before work began in 2017 the union
estimated the bill would be
57 million but by january this year
the total cost was just over 98
million pounds the big question for
unite and its members was this building
worth it
it was supposed to save the union money
on hotel bills and conference costs
but now it seems that the millions spent
here could take
years even decades to make back
one of the candidates who wants to
succeed len mccluskey says members want
answers
they struggle to understand how the
union could spend
nearly a hundred million pounds on a
four-star hotel
and conferencing facility that doesn't
give them the workplace support and
backing
the very reason that they joined the
trade union for
the lack of transparency huge overspend
concerns about tendering
and the fact len mccluskey is unites
only paid elected official
meant we wanted to speak to him
the union ignored our request so we went
to the london headquarters
to try and find him
before eventually getting through by
phone
we just wanted to speak to you if it's
possible about your birmingham hotel and
coffee he told us to call the press
office
and they said mr mccluskey did not want
to do an interview
put the phone down
when we asked unite they told us their
initial estimate for the project was too
low
but the costs increased over time money
was also spent adding an extra floor to
the building
and turning it from a three to a four
star hotel they reject a lack of
openness in the tendering process
saying len mccluskey wasn't involved but
they will not name other companies who
applied for the contract
this building will be len mccluskey's
legacy
the race to succeed him officially
begins within weeks
joe pike sky news birmingham